I accidentally became a meme and this is  that story I'm saying day I am probably  best known for the viral video Chocolate  Rain I uploaded Chocolate Rain to  YouTube as an afterthought it wasn't  intended as the final version it was  just an experimental ballad in poem it  did not blow up immediately someone  eventually posted it on dig.com someone  saw it there they posted it on 4chan I  would say it became viral largely in  part because I had a voice body mismatch  you know I look like Bruno Mars I sound  like Barry White I move like Mr Bean and  a lot of 4chan's audience saw me as a  potential patron saint as sort of like  oh this is a nerd he's totally not  self-aware and he's being big and loud  and this is like perfect and it started  to go massively viral